la presidenta Dina boluarte fue
interrogada por la fiscal general de
Perú en la indagación que realiza el
Ministerio Público por la 60 muertes
ocurridas durante las protestas contra
su gobierno la fiscalía suspendió el
interrogatorio hasta que la justicia
peruana resuelva una tutela de derechos
presentada por las procuraduría general
que pide que el organismo participe para
defender al estado en las declaraciones
de los investigados la presidenta
boluarte el Primer Ministro Alberto
tarola y otros funcionarios son
investigados por presuntos delitos de
genocidio homicidio calificado lesiones
graves al respecto del ministro de
Justicia José Tello afirmó que boluarte
está colaborando con la justicia para
que todos los hechos sean esclarecidos y
hoy también se realizó una audiencia de
prisión preventiva contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo la fiscalía
sustentó el requerimiento de 36 meses de
prisión contra el ex mandatario por los
presuntos delitos de organización
criminal tráficos de influencias y
colusión y afirmó que Castillo podría
ser condenado a 32 años de cárcel si es
que es hallado culpable por su parte
Casio negó ser autor y formar una
organización criminal denunció que se
forma un proceso contra él por supuestas
acusaciones sin fundamento y dijo que se
encuentra preso porque comenzó a cobrar
deudas a empresas que le deben impuestos
al país y señaló que varios de sus
ministros que son investigados tuvieron
la aprobación del parlamento el juez
Juan Carlos chekley continuará la
audiencia El jueves 9 a las 15 horas
para anunciar su veredicto